à 82 ans bryan singer est devenu ce
lundi matin la première personne à
recevoir le vaccin mis au point par le
laboratoire astrazeneca et l'université
d'oxford et bien le vaccin signifie tout
pour moi à mon avis c'est le seul moyen
de retourner à un peu de vie normale ce
virus est terrible non alors que le
sérum de l'américain pfizer a déjà été
injectés à plus d'un million de
britanniques les autorités du royaume
uni vont désormais pouvoir distribuer
massivement le vaccin astrazeneca oxford
100 millions de doses ont été commandées
par londres
thaksin c'est un nouveau vaccin c'est
une nouvelle production
chaque lot doit être examinée avant
d'être distribués nous avons environ un
demi million de doses d'astrazeneca
cette semaine nous en recevrons plus au
cours des semaines et des mois à venir
mais notre objectif au nhs est
d'injecter les vaccins que ce soit celui
de pfizer ou d'astrazeneca dans les bras
des gens dès que nous le recevons donc
si nous recevons deux millions de
vaccins par semaine alors notre objectif
est d'en injecter à autant de personnes
de son côté boris johnson s'est rendu ce
lundi après midi dans un hôpital
londonien pour observer le personnel
hospitalier à pied d'oeuvre
un peu plus tôt dans la matinée son
ministre de la santé avait qualifié le
démarrage des injections du vaccin
astrazeneca oxford comme un tournant
pour la vaccination britannique
c'est une situation très difficile en
termes de propagation du virus
mais nous avons aussi c'est très bonne
nouvelle ce matin c'est réellement un
moment charnière avec l'arrivée du
vaccin d'astrazeneca oxford dont les
hôpitaux du royaume uni outre le royaume
il argentine et l'inde ont également
autorisé l'utilisation du vaccin
astrazeneca oxford
de son côté l'agencé européenne du
médicament a jugé la semaine dernière
comme peu probable une autorisation dès
le mois de janvier du sérum britannique
au sein de l'union européenne